vous avez vu dans une nouvelle BD la
Schtroumpfette de portera plus de talon
ça y est c'est tombé
ça m'a pris regardez elle aurait quatre
c'est incroyable de fou
apparu en 1958 les Schtroumpfs faisons
devenus au fil des années des
personnages de cartoon emblématiques
avec des dizaines d'albums au compteur
des films et des dessins animés de menu
culte ça va aujourd'hui
mais aujourd'hui alors qu'un nouvel
album s'apprête à paraître ces petites
créatures qui vivent dans la forêt vont
pour la première fois être modifié par
de nouveaux dessinateurs ça fait des
mois et des mois que je refais les pages
je retravaille tout en permanence
en plus de se doter de nouveaux visages
des changements majeurs vont être opérés
si je trouve ce costaud va par exemple
se débarrasser de son tatouage
Schtroumpfette va quant à elle perdre
ses talons une annonce choc qui a fait
schtroumpfer certains fans de la saga
alors Schtroumpfette ne portera plus de
talons comprenez-vous cette décision
[Musique]
c'est quoi la question c'est pas
comprenez vous cette décision
c'est insupportable franchement c'est
insupportable c'est quoi le message mais
les femmes n'est rien non les femmes
sont libres
toi aussi tu vas être libre ça existe de
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il est lourd
sont pas aussi grandes qu'on le pense
moi ma femme quand elle a 20 cm de talon
c'est une autre personne allez
on adore on enchaîne oui mais moi
franchement ça me fait flipper on va
demander Obélix de faire comme j'aime
parce que c'est grossofu je te jure
n'importe quoi les questions que je me
pose c'est en 70 ans de Schtroumpf
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un une fois qui
a dit tiens la Schtroumpfette à des
talons c'est non personne n'a dit ça en
fait ce qui me fait peur c'est qu'on
veut instaurer une société où on tolère
les différences ou on tolère tout le
monde en fait on veut que tout le monde
s'en pareil soit pareil on veut que les
femmes soient des hommes que les hommes
soient des femmes tout le monde se
ressemblent c'est une uniformisation qui
fait flipper et c'est n'importe quoi on
met sur la tête pour un album parce
qu'en fait ils vont faire tourner les
d'abord avec ses talons ensuite le pire
c'est que c'était la seule femme vous
rendez compte la semaine
la séance maquiller comme ça avec des
talons c'est du sexisme absolu
était sexistes totalement et enfin la
révolution arrive et vous devriez tous
vous êtes tous des réactionnaires vous
ne voyez pas que le nouveau monde est en
marche moi je dis vive les nouveaux
Schtroumpfs serrer les bravo et non on
ne reviendra plus en arrière Valérie non
jamais sexiste il y avait pas une
tournante sur la sur la Schtroumpf avec
les Schtroumpfs
faire de dire que il se la tapé tous et
ça t'a fait tout en quoi
toi tu as fini
le plus gros problème aujourd'hui avec
l'honneur de la Schtroumpfette
le problème c'est quoi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on veut que les hommes
soient des femmes les hommes soient des
femmes qui aiment différents il y aura
toujours des différences ne serait-ce
que physique ne serait-ce que biologique
une femme n'est pas un homme un homme
n'est pas une femme moi je suis à
l'ancienne ça très beau quand je vois
mon père qui sort dans la voiture qui
fait le tour et qui ouvre la porte pour
que sa femme sorte je sois très jolie
alors on fait plus ça aussi elle est
obligatoire
[Applaudissements]
c'est joli encore le truc à l'ancienne
pourquoi elle aurait des talons
laissez-les
talons c'est qu'on est un peu et qu'on
est blonde c'est qu'on a un peu
authentique du cul quoi bah non on peut
avoir des talons et à tout ça normal par
définition sur des caricatures tu avais
le Schtroumpf Grognon qui avait la
gueule
non mais Siri moi je peux pas entendre
ça mais c'est impossible
que tous les nains n'ont pas baissé
Blanche-Neige
tes yeux parce qu'il est allergique aux
poils de chat
[Applaudissements]
les chansons
je veux pas rentrer là-dedans
je rentre pas dans les allergies
de Gilles Verdez
puisque c'est évidemment sexiste parce
que c'est une injonction de sa féminin
du tout elle a le choix elle fait ce
qu'elle veut oh là je trouve ça atteigne
le choix
ça existe pas connard
[Applaudissements]
qui trouve que c'est bien parce que
c'est voilà c'est un bon symbole
franchement tu es complètement décadant
Gilles
progressiste
il faut faire un référendum pour ça et
je pense que 100% des gens
mais c'est les forces de la réaction
c'est n'importe quoi
mes amis à part tes amis voilà 3% c'est
tes amis c'est le prochain score qui
seront
prochaine élections je te le dis tes
amis là non mais à part tes amis qui qui
dit ça là on les connaît on les connaît
on les connaît